we're talking all things prawns here
actually I'm with chef Jamie Oliver our
co-host for the show today we're cooking
up some recipes from his latest cookbook
the uh five ingredients Mediterranean um
I'm obsessed because Jamie is actually
going to teach us right now how to cook
the cover star of the book which I feel
like I'm I'm really excited to make this
dish okay Jamie please should we start
school is in session we got five
ingredients You Beautiful People um you
know we got the pastor of your choice
I'm using a nice little tagini we got
parsley but you could use any herbs you
wish uh here's the little kind of thing
to look out for that you might not have
used before this is called Harissa you
can get it in the supermarkets uh it's
really tasty it's ground chili oil some
sort of delicate spices it's a Tunisian
space yes I love hares do you I do it's
Smoky yes um but without being anything
like a Chipotle and it's not too hot
it's just got nice hum to it so that in
conjunction with lemon and prawns is
five beautiful ingredients just wanting
to come together so first up in the pan
and this this might gross some people
out but like let's just go with it
because it's important that we talk
about Flavor we need to earn flavor so
I'm going to put these heads into the
pan I've eaten shrimp heads I love them
you can eat them they go crispy but you
don't have to eat them many people take
them out but it's actually not the head
you want it's the flavor inside so let's
just wind back here is the prawn I just
wanted to show you how to prep it a lot
of people are scared of doing it so the
head goes off and goes into the pan off
with their head yeah that's where the
flavor is creamy delicious sort of depth
of flavor I'm going to peel it down like
this and then I want to show you how to
Butterfly it's a nice little technique
to learn just take a knife like that
down the back down the back and then you
got a little vein here that you can
remove right which people always go uh
with right you want to remove that and
then what will happen is when that cooks
it'll butterfly it'll open out that
means it's going to trap flavor just
like the pasta and then you're going to
eat it it's going to be delicious so
let's marinate these it's so surreal now
it's so surreal Jamie this is like I sit
at home and watch you and here we are
and I know we've so many times this your
family that's right you know what it is
actually so it is if you can put a
couple of teaspoons of Harissa in there
yes we're going to do a simple little
marinade so we'll mix this up like that
that will go into the butterfly prawns
as I said big ones or small ones here
what I'm going to do is just turn this
heat up a little bit here let's just get
that pump in now we're just going to
give that a little toss you can see when
you cook the heads actually they change
color right so this yeah yeah absolutely
I wonder what you said then it's
definitely I can't say pink without
saying pink that's all right I'll say it
get I'll say one again I'm a lot lemon
lemon so we're going to take the lemon
here lemon and chili best friends we'll
put a little bit of lemon juice into
here uh as we sort of start bringing the
temperature up here let's get frying um
I'm going to move them around as I
squash the heads sort of this gorgeous
sort of creaminess comes out right
that's the bit that might gross people
out but that is ladies and gentlemen
where the flavor is so we get it out
we're going to use herbs bit of uh
parsley here what's your knife skills
like
Drew um have you done have you you can
use knife cross Chop Tap chop Rock chop
all of that business no I'm going to
just admit it right now no the safest
way to cook is cross chopping like this
fingers flat on the top and you can do
that nice and fine that's what I teach
my kids when they're sort of like know
78 years old you know tell you know
teaching the family kids like how to
have a board put a wet cloth underneath
it so it doesn't move you know we start
with cross chopping just kind of moving
it around like that it's really really
good for veggies or I like that you put
the stems in there yeah they're sweet
and and delicious give that a little
toss my darling I'm going to go in with
the pasta or as you call it pasta um
we're going to just turn it up
here nice